on va jouer à ce qu'on appelle le
bourricot pour gagner tout de suite une
place pour la laponie la totalité et là
il y aura des jours les chéris par
ailleurs nous accélérons par le 29
novembre moi je l'avais dit bientôt on
dira bien sûr les personnages agissent
sous pression dira les deux personnes
qui viendront avec nous et qui
participeront tous les chéris je vous
dis tout de suite j'ai eu la chance de
voir on aller habiter cette offre godard
car c'est les igloos des igloos c'est
pas des igloos mais par contre vous
allez kiffer alors pour ceux qui veulent
participer
vous allez sur le twitter bien sûr de
tpm pays et tout est expliqué pour ce
qui peut parler oui ah oui ça tu faisais
quelque chose à l'oreille qu'est ce qui
se passe me lever alors oui à tous vous
voulez revoir la laponie
elle me dit si vous voulez redécouvrir
la vie est ce que ceux qui sont
qualifiés ils sont contents de ce qu'ils
sont pas qualifiés l'histoire ils sont
carrément envie de venir regarder la
laponie
regardez ce que ça va être
[Musique]
il
à
[Musique]
à voir
alors voilà c'est tout excité alors les
chalets à ce qu'on appelle le bourricot
le bourricot de noël
c'est très sain vous connaissez ce jeu
le bourricot vous devenez des trucs sur
le lan voilà et là le moment va faire la
ligue en lan soleil celui qui fait lever
l'année l'éliminer d'accord avec des
médailles la folie la nuit du jeu l'agra
la fin celui qui n'aura jamais fait le
vélane way sera qualifié et aura son
billet pour la laponie
j'ai fait un gagnant gagnant ce soir on
recommence onze fois
[Rires]
allez c'est parti on y va on va faire
leur gros comme ça allait bernard oui
car l'hiver n'a pas dit vient
normalement
vas-y allez hop valley berna c'est bien
là c'est bien voilà nicolas pernikoff
avec ce france très visuel numéro 35
c'est un programme qui passait son il
est validé et après lesquelles il aurait
initié si bella ça allait mais qu'il
réponde et au nom de bella les cabines
est obligé de me pousser
non mais sans rire toute la lumière sur
des objets de l'aide n'est pas compliqué
il appelle mon niveau isabelle
morini-bosc ses 20 56 fois le groupe m6
certaines en droit par un ami 23 validé
[Applaudissements]
dumas dit mme aminata tall et si on
n'est pas là dans une heure on
recommence attention c'est bon c'est
parti là qu'était philippe thürler nous
renchérit n'entend pas laisser partir
car caroline ithurbide qui peut partir
peut-être dit c'est bon merci d'y aller
comme ça allait christine kelly du csa
est ce que c'est cette année et courir
aux commentaires qui laissait sa
compatible pense pas mais là c'est
dégueulasse et un cactus aussi
s'accroître un pic à cactus dégueulasse
l'avantagé quand tu commences le premier
là mais ouais mais c'est normal ça nous
arrange et pour beaucoup là bas mais
quand je met du coup voir kélian la
faute à pas de chance à chaque surface
et sert à rien de chercher un emploi
moins lourde qui permet et libye n'agit
il peut mettre là que j'ai connu ce jeu
mais dame nature passe là bas
oh là là faut tu m'énerves all all oméga
et valérie attentif au débat ce soir
bennati dégagerait du bénin mais toi ça
passe ah bon on passe l'école affaire
nicolas
je rappelle sylvain nicolas pernikoff
comme qu'il faut c'est ce qu'ils disent
oui à ces fonds et non tao pas une mort
permis à aller voter
morgane d'engeances tendu m'engager
[Applaudissements]
attention kenny vous repartez sait par
qui
kelly v novelli elle répondait tout nu
de belles allées schouppe est allé les
croix aller mais ça rien de temps en
temps au début il va parler dans le vide
ah ouais non mais je vous le saurez
jamais banal un cheval de course
mettez vous à la veille de leur mort
fera jamais d'un dauphins requins du ca
pour vous merci d'être avec nous les
cherry on va voir qui se qualifie pour
la la fin tu me rappelle qu'on est à un
haut niveau
allez vas-y fille gilles vas-y cette
peine a dit gilles savary gilou
et là quelle bernese on a perdu on a
perdu vers des biens souvent merci mon
chemin non balle a alors quand il est là
c'est à lanières de l'ira samedi soir tu
mets ta nea c'est pas le mec tu balances
à dos combattants après invités
également à la wii allez c'est parti
tu penses que tu m'apportes essence tout
à l'heure vous manque et tout le
week-end trauma kitsch tout agitée pour
trouver allait arriver et années faciles
à cocody benayou attendent avant mme
abena pour l'instant t
tout cela peut partir en laponie segal
et de l'équipe des calomnies wires pas
génial d'aller sur des comptes a
largement devant le truc on dirait
qu'elle arrive devant une burqa mais
qu'est ce qui rend le à la tour eiffel a
le droit il contredit connaît les salles
à ça on fait la queue non non je vais
aussi évasif yeux tu es bon allez
normal bach échir après je vais prendre
une grande décision après ce tour si
vous êtes éliminé les chéris mais
maintenant je vous le dis vous les 6 à 2
3 4 5 6 on va faire trois équipes de
deux et alaa les deux qui restent on
s'affronteront la contrôlons dakar ok je
me faisais n'a alors donc voila vous
deux vous deux d'accord les filles
attention c'est parti à gauche
maintenant c'est comme voiture alors
allez-y venez tous là mais pourquoi
comment ça non mais à chacun non n'est
pas passée restera pas chez eux c'est
des chiens galeux
attention ça fait pas mal de tracas à la
maison un certain temps vas-y à bercy
donc je joue ensemble et après la finale
plus adroits en mettant une pression
[Applaudissements]
mon plateau on pourra compléter à
telezüri
attention pour la finale pour la finale
s'est pas retiré vivant des délits et
caroline ithurbide contre eux ou
messieurs je ne sais pas qui vous êtes
vous êtes très sympa je vous fait une
belle équipe où la mère n'a à l'esat
attend à l'est non non je déconne pas en
bas âge assure en même temps en même
temps les filles savent être en même
temps dit sa place pour rien au liberia
là ça va être dur noté comme quoi tout
comme attentant quant à moi j'aime bien
la valeur semble alixan me mets dans mes
il faut mettre des trucs là où je vais
non je croyais et je crois le
bergamasque entourage et le droit avec
la ou un truc comme l'as tu t'es cru ou
là il faut se mettre là
on ne blague pas beau rythme et harry la
finale aller des demi finales chercheurs
attention la finale oppose
quel beau à caroline et bien des deux a
gagné en béton sous taillé pour la la
fois du son une d'accord les chéris
attention c'est parti on passait banques
et les vélos vélib en caroline ithurbide
séoul qui commençait car ses parents la
famille tic le dis et je vous le dis et
avant le vide attention qui va être
qualifié pour la laponie kelly vdo v10
ou caroline étions je stressais vous
avez envie d'y aller car on est comme ça
mais c'est mon rêve d'enfant mais je
suis stressé s'agir je tremble une belle
finale
une belle finale on est tous on stresse
pas julie moi je vous adore toutes les
deux pour moi l'une ou l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci